baby baby baby
[Music]
the carpenters owned the charts in the
70s with hits like top of the world
rainy days and mondays and we've only
just begun and now we can relive those
hits with carpenter's legacy over at the
mint and here tell us more this is sally
olsen who plays karen carpenter and ned
mills who plays richard carpenter
welcome you guys hey hi it's great to
have you guys on the show good to be
here i mean the look you guys have it
down
i mean that's a compliment you spot on
with the look thank you for those that
are that are not familiar with the
carpenters we have a couple interns i
said you guys know who the carpenters
are and they said no who were the
carpenters yeah well the carpenters were
a brother sister duo karen and richard
and they were the biggest selling
uh duo act of the 70s sold over 100
million records wow so many hit songs
what can we expect in the show yeah what
we're going to do of course all the
carpenters greatest hits as you
mentioned top of the world and and we've
only just begun close to you all the
greatest hits but the other thing that
we uh like to do we are recreating their
1976 uk tour where they add a lot of
surprise
energetic entertaining moments in the
show during that part of their career
they had broadway consultants come in to
make the show more of a show and less of
a concert with ballot after ballad
because what you do on an album doesn't
always translate to a live show so with
that said they
they had karen do a big exciting drum
feature and richard was also doing a
classical feature and richard was a big
fan of spike jones so they did this
spike jones parody of close to you so
those are some of the fun things that we
integrate into the show has richard seen
you guys perform
not yet he was actually invited to our
performance that we did in downey
california where they were from and it
was his wedding anniversary so he said
his best and said maybe next time so
fingers crossed when did you discover
that you had this talent and had the
look well i started performing as karen
about seven years ago i'm originally
from vermont and then by 2018 i ventured
out to las vegas to check things out and
because i had ideas of where i wanted to
take the show and
ideas of how i wanted to further further
develop it and mutual friends introduced
me to ned and ed was interested in the
project and i needed somebody to play
the role of the brother richard and he
was a guy the rest is history i mean do
you have a favorite song to perform
because we opened with a clip of you
guys but when we opened that clip i told
you i was first watching i thought it
was the carpenters do you have a
favorite song to perform wow there's i
love so many of them
probably to perform would be superstar
and i need to be in love
yeah superstar for me as well and i
loved it the classical moment that i get
we kind of take it give it a little left
turn i do a little version of gershwin's
rhapsody in blue for a couple of minutes
kind of show when sally came to you and
asked you to be a part of this project
what was your first thought make sure i
can do richard carpenter oh i need to
study that's a great question because
before this i did a short stint playing
the role of jerry lee lewis okay this
show called killer cashier king this is
a whole little bit different thing and i
was like oh it's you know it was easy i
was so naive about the musical
complexity uh richard carpenter was a
monster jazz pianist and i had much
bigger shoes to fill than i realized i
had a lot of work in front of me putting
it together arranging the music and
we're kind of like if you will a
mom-and-pop operation she does graphic
design and costumes and i do the
technical music side and it makes a
great team it's a great show it's an
award-winning show thank you so much for
joining guys we really appreciate it
it's gonna be a blast thank you thank
you for coming in today thank you and if
they act now it's lv now 75 right
because
they can get 75 off that's huge right
there the carpenters the carpenters the
las vegas residency at the mint it
starts what's already started right the
show's taking place now correct starts
tomorrow starts tomorrow okay they'll
take the stage tuesdays wednesdays and
thursdays at four and seven o'clock
visit carpenterslegacy.com again that
coupon code lv now free the first 150
people who respond get free admission
must be 21